Let's go to our caller from the seven zero
one.
Area code.
Who's calling from seven 01 today?
Oh, yeah, that's you.
OK.
So this is she's sorry.
This is Nathan from North Dakota.
Great.
So.
My question is, so I live about 100 miles
south of the border of Canada.
And North Dakota is a deep, like, in my opinion,
in deep red red state.
Yes.
So if if heaven forbid.
So I'm a little nervous.
That's OK.
If, heaven forbid, that Donald Trump wins
another term.
Yes.
Would it be seen as an act of cowardice?
To move to the north, to Canada.
I mean, I wouldn't call it cowardice, I would
call it pragmatic.
It's difficult to move to Canada, so I don't
know that it's that easy to do.
But I wouldn't see it as an act of cowardice.
No, I would see it as, hey, I'm taking control
of my life.
The election didn't go my way.
I believe that this is such a danger.
I don't want to be governed by this orange
maniac.
I'm going to go somewhere else.
I mean, if it's good work, if you can get
it, so to speak, like it's difficult to move
to Canada.
But if you're able to do it, I would not call
that cowardice at all.
Yeah, it's just nice.
With everything on on it just I don't think
I could take another another four years of
living in a country where I just seen what
the leader is doing.
So now could you move to Canada?
Like, do you have relatives there or how would
you do it legally?
Yes, I have.
About my mom's side.
I have an entire set of family over there.
Wow.
Well, that's certainly something to think
about.
You know, a lot of people talk about, I mean,
and move to Canada if X or Y, very few people
ever really do it.
So it would be it would be an interesting
thing to look at.
All percent.
All right.
Thank you for the phone call.
I don't know that we've ever had a caller
from North Dakota.
It's interesting.